bonjour à vous michel raimbault merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france alors c'est donc un procès on
peut le dire historique qui s'ouvre en
israël puisque c'est la première fois
qu'un chef de gouvernement fait l'objet
de telles accusations
oui c'est la première fois qu'elles sont
si ce n'est pas un événement inattendu
puisqu'on en parle maintenant la triple
triple chefs d'accusation si on veut
contre punchline
benyamin nétanyahou est bien connu les
affaires entre alliés pendant très très
longtemps a provoqué au moins trois
élections en israël et donc mais comme
j'aime la tania loup est un homme très
très habile et qu'il a pu trouver un
terrain d'entente avec son contenu en
principal benny ganz finalement ça ne
changera pas rien du tout finalement la
politique d'israël font là est bien le
principe plutôt que le procès de
benyamin nétanyahou la fraude la
corruption la ville conscient d'alu
confiance finalement c'est bruxelles
d'hommes politiques je dirais que c'est
un délit relativement courantes ou en
tout cas et pas seulement en israël dans
pleins mais ceci moi je trouve qu'il ya
un tragique on va certainement suivre ce
procès de près quand il aura lieu on a
la solution qui a été trouvée avec une
alternance de mois pour chacun des opus
à lui dire de benny ganz et aminata vous
montre assez la fusion l'identité d'une
complète entre les deux hommes en ce
concerne la politique israélienne est là
est bien le problème puisque la police
israélienne elle va se poursuivre sans
changement procès ou pas
corruption confiance mi temps ils fraude
ou pas c'est ça le problème je la mets
vins pour les balais steen la
transaction du siècle de basse
contrebasse continuer puisque miami
natanyahou dans un premier temps je
pense va rester premier ministre et
qu'il va poursuivre ses bus c'est à dire
d'un canon dans le cadre datant du
siècle et les projets insight vient
d'annexer notamment la vallée du
jourdain des colonies israéliennes en
cisjordanie ce qui réduira d'autant
je dirais encore ça réduira encore plus
ce qui restait de la les atolls
palestiniens se sont du coup les
postillons palestiniens qui varie en
cisjordanie
côté de la masse compacte la zone de
confinement généralisée qu'est la bande
de gaza donc ça va donner du pain
produits encore plus de déséquilibres et
ça réduit évidemment en purée là là au
moins dans le temps présent essalouh g
mouvement ce que vous dites là michel
raimbault ce que vous dites c'est que
quelle que soit l'issue de ce procès
benny ganz va assurer d'huile à la
continuité de la politique israélienne
que comprenait un bennani netanyahu
parce que dans son dans le temps je suis
pas dans les secrets de surveillance pas
plus dans ce natanyahou mais d'après ce
que l'on en sait les deux programmes
électoraux et notamment ce qui concerne
le volet palestinien la politique global
régional d'israël
il n'avait absolument pas la blague de
ce monsieur nathaniel appelle sa
démarche historique
ça allait bien réglé et je pensais pas
monsieur benny ganz qui mettra fin et
c'est ça le drame filaments pour les
palestiniens parce qu'il n'y a pas de
règlement mais l'affection palestiniens
normalement à ses amis siècle ou pas
sans un consentement n'est pas le sien
alors il ya une opposition totale et
c'est la ruine finalement de tout la
légalité internationale plus qu'à
l'égalité attendant ils ont visé si
elles avaient été mises en oeuvre
c'est ce qui est une solution à deux
états avec près une négociation devient
qu'une négociation là seulement donc une
démarche unilatérale avec l'appui régir
à 100% de messieurs trump et deux au
fond il faut bien dire d'une certaine
complicité de la communauté
internationale puisqu'on leicester
israël et qu'on apprenait on a appris
son parti disons de cette impuissance
des nations unies et aux vallées du
pourtant qu'ils devraient être les
parrains de toute solution puisque
israël a été créé par la résolution des
nations unies michèle rameau pour
revenir donc au préfet
le premier ministre israélien benyamin
nétanyahou ne dispose d'aucune immunité
judiciaire mais la différence c'est vrai
des autres élus il n'a pas à
démissionner le temps du procès
s'agissant de l'immunité judiciaire
ça veut dire qu'il peut être condamné et
comme celle actuelle sur assure le
nouveau gouvernement d'union
oui mais peut-être que je pense que l'un
des souhaits de monsieur natanyahou
enfin ce qu'il avait en vue ce qui est
logique de son point de vue je me
justifie pas mais c'était finalement de
s'il reste au gouvernement il avait
davantage de chances d'obtenir le vote
dix optent de mesures qui auraient qui
lui aurait assuré une immunité limitée
siècle chose qui n'existe pas
actuellement je crois pour les premiers
ministres israéliens
donc il faut rester premier mix le temps
n'étant mis en en procès et on revoir
même en étant condamné s'il était
condamné je sais pas ce qu'ils feraient
le ballon mais je pense que monsieur
maintiennent la louve cherche à obtenir
en étant au pouvoir ils n'obtiendraient
pas se quitter le pouvoir
en restant premier ministre cherche à
obtenir une bonne voie
ils ont appuyé les parlements distingue
bien pour lui donner
ils ont une certaine mesure de nature et
l'immunité à l'avenir contre tous pro
sectes et de mettre à l'abri des
poursuites mais globalement ou moins de
20 des sondés poursuit le maire
merci beaucoup michel à rambo merci
d'avoir été en direct avec nous font